hello everybody welcome to another
python mathematics and
stock indicators tutorial video in this
video we're going to be discussing
shaken volatility if you couldn't
guess shaken volatility is a measure of
volatility
so it's kind of like average true range
and in fact i would probably prefer
average true range over shaken
volatility
uh as far as you know measure of
volatility is concerned because
basically um or even bollinger bands but
the good thing about shaking volatility
but also average true range
is going to be the it spits out uh
just a single line right so you can
throw that number into all sorts of
other formulas so it makes it very
friendly to use
elsewhere besides you know just that
indicator
the calculation of shaking volatility is
pretty simple um
even though i have it broken down into
three steps it's really just one step
it's percent change of x you know from x
periods ago of the ema minus
of high minus low but to
break it down first you're going to
calculate high minus low then you're
going to calculate the exponential
moving
average of that high minus low
and that exponential moving average will
be whatever you choose
typically uh 10 and 10 is used so 10 ema
and then 10 from x periods ago it's just
going to be like a 10.
so anyway step two calculate the ema of
the high minus the low
done and then step three is just
calculate the percent change
of that you know ema right
and it's kind of like a moving percent
change so it's not like a
real percent change it's more like a
moving percent change from
10 periods ago or however many you want
but usually you're going to see a 10
10. let's go ahead and look at some
examples
real quick so here is our little
charting application if you want to know
more about how we built this entire
charting application
you can watch that charting stocks and
python tutorial series
um but anyway this is the charting
application here
we will be working on it and the like
the actual code i'm just going to give
to you guys and you can work on adding
the formulas in here
because it'll just come with this little
thing here blank so anyways this is the
shaken volatility for att or just t
is it symbol so as you can see you know
as it's getting really volatile
both here it goes up a little bit and
then it continues being very volatile so
it really rockets up here so it's a
little lagging
but not much uh then it shoots back up
again but then it starts kind of getting
stable and sure enough it does kind of
just kind of relax down here
at this line as you can see here it's
going to sort of oscillate around a zero
line but not by very much but yeah you
can get into the negatives
but generally you're going to see a
positive movement here
um so anyway and again here it's kind of
volatile
it comes up but it kind of relaxes and
again you can kind of see the line just
kind of chills out
so it's just mostly i mean obviously
shaking volatility it's purely just a
measure of volatility it's there's no
trending or anything like that
in here you can usually also see that
shaken volatility is going to somewhat
mimic the volume line so when volume
really spikes you'll probably see
shaken volatility spike but again i
would say the
average true range is probably the
better uh measurement there
anyway uh so this is the indicator that
we're going to be covering in the next
couple videos so if that sounds
interesting to you guys you should uh
continue on in the next video in the
next video we'll be calculating it
within python
and then in the video after that we'll
actually chart it up on this exact
charting application here so anyways as
always thanks for watching